هناك الكثير من الطعام المذهل في
الفلبين ، ولكن هناك
تقليدًا رائعًا للطهي وهو كبير بما يكفي
لإطعام الجيش ،
مرحبًا أنا تشاك وأنا أملك سأحارب مانيلا
بودل ما هي معركة بوذا
[موسيقى]
سأقاتل إنها مجموعة وليمة  فوق
أوراق الموز ، مجرد طعام مكدس في
المنتصف مع وقوف الجميع جنبًا
إلى جنب في أفضل جزء هو أن الجميع
يأكل بأيديهم العارية ، لقد نشأ ذلك
مع أخذ الجنود العسكريين الفلبينيين
التدريب إلى المنزل وأصبح الأمر
سائدًا لدرجة أن الطهاة مثل
جيف الآن  لديك وظائف بدوام كامل تجلب
معارك بودل إلى الجماهير ، فإن
معركة بودل هي مثال جوهري على كيفية
تقدير الفلبينيين للمشاركة خاصة عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالطعام ، سواء بالنسبة
لبوذا حاول أن يستمتع بالطريقة التي من
المفترض أن تكون عجلة في سوق بالينتواك ،
هذا هو  عندما يجتمع قتال بوذا
معًا ، سنحتاج إلى
الأساسيات لذلك
الدجاج والمأكولات البحرية
والحلويات الجانبية وبالطبع الفواكه
ولا تنسى الموظفون  rt من العرض ،
أوراق الموز
shoosh أنا ممتلئ بالفعل نبدأ
بجزء فوضوي بشوي أولاً
دجاج لحم الخنزير والمأكولات البحرية ثم
تقطع الخضار على البخار
مع الروبيان وسرطان البحر
ثم نقطع جميع الجوانب
وتحضير المائدة بعد إعداد أوراق الموز
من المهم البحث عن
وسط المائدة والبدء من هناك
يمكنك وضع الحلوى والفواكه
ثم على الجانبين ابدأ بالأرز
ولحم الخنزير والدجاج والمأكولات البحرية لجعلها
لذيذة للغاية في  على الجانبين حرفياً
على جانب الطاولة ، يوجد في
الفلبين الكثير من الخيارات عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالطعام ، ولكن لا يوجد شيء مقارنة بالمجتمع
الذي يتطور عند مشاركة كومة من
الطعام بدون أيدي مع من تحبهم
[موسيقى]